[Music]
Republicans on the House Intelligence
Committee or taking the next step in
trying to prove that the Democrat funded
Trump dossier was wrongly used as
justification for much of the
investigation into alleged collusion
with the Russians chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge shows
us the latest tactic current and former
government officials including former
FBI director James Comey former CIA
director John Brennan and former
intelligence chief james clapper have
until Friday to town the House
Intelligence Committee when they knew
the Trump dossier was funded by the DNC
and Clinton campaign subpoenas are in
play if they don't answer those 10
questions truthfully
and fully they yes responding to
Republican allegations earlier this
month that the FBI Justice Department
were guilty of surveillance abuses
during the 2016 campaign the Democrats
counter memo was released over the
weekend with redactions at the FBI's
request Democrats conclude there was
intelligence beyond the Trump dossier to
justify surveillance of a campaign aide
the FBI acted appropriately and seeking
a warrant and Carter page they're not
part of some deep State as the president
apparently would like the public to
believe the Democrat said multiple
sources which are redacted corroborate
dossier allegations but this appears to
conflict with former FBI director James
Comey 'he's 2017 congressional testimony
three months after the page surveillance
warrant in October 2016 Comey briefed
the incoming president at Trump Tower
and still considered the dossier
salacious and unverified the Democrats
also emphasized the FISA Court knew the
dossier was a political document but
specifics about who funded the project
were prompted me with health because of
the FBI's long-standing tradition to
protect sources the bottom line with the
court is this that we can't have a
secret court operate like this in
America where they're gonna take and use
it against political enemies the
Republican memo said former FBI deputy
director Andrew McCain testified that
the bureau would never have sod the page
surveillance warrant without the dossier
the Democrats do not directly challenge
the finding and it gets only a passing
reference in the press release back
sheet right Kevin thank you